et the extra-terrestrial is a
masterpiece and one of the
highest-grossing films of all time it's
a simple story an alien gets lost in a
generic suburb a lonely little boy named
Elliot takes him in and - they establish
a profound psychic and emotional bond
Elliot and his siblings help et phone
home to his planet of origin for a
rescue Oh et phone home but first they
have to make sure et gets off of Earth
without being obliterated by creepy
government agents young et fans who grew
up into adults may notice that the movie
is a little different than they might
remember there are all kinds of details
great and small that flew right over
kids heads like there were a mob of
alien protecting tweens on bikes these
are the things you only notice in et as
an adult no grown-ups allowed et the
extra-terrestrial is a kids movie this
isn't to say that it's a movie for kids
but more than it is literally a movie
full of kids it's a look into kid world
how kids react to divorce how kids have
their own secret suburban societies how
kids conceal and help a friendly alien
visitor and how kids fight a bunch of
government spooks a kid might not be
totally aware that it's a big deal
they're seeing themselves up on that
screen because it reflects their
everyday life which is kids only with
the occasional adult interruption in
fact for most of the movie the only
adult face you'll see is that of
Elliot's mother
despite a lengthy classroom scene
audiences don't see Elliot's teachers
face and then when adults do show up
they're mostly bad guys to enhance the
movie's childlike point of view Steven
Spielberg the Boy Wonder of the movies
shot a lot of the film at a kid's eye
level what's your name
audiences learn a lot about Elliot over
the course of ET the extra-terrestrial
he's about 11 years old loves red hooded
sweatshirts lives in the suburbs has two
siblings and he can connect
telepathically with an alien as for that
alien he has a glowing finger and
delight of heart can bring plants back
to life
he likes beer and candy and is just
trying to get home
and that's about all we know about
Elliot and et one thing that becomes
clear upon viewing with jaded nitpicky
adult eyes neither Elliot's last name
nor et's real name are ever given can
you say et et PD Elliot and all the
other kids just call their magical alien
visitor et short for extraterrestrial
they can live in each other's minds but
a simple name exchange never occurs
obvious product placement one of the
most endearing scenes in ET occurs when
Elliot fully befriends his little alien
roommates by enticing him with a trail
of well-placed Reese's Pieces the gentle
telekinetic alien at the heart of et
just can't get enough of those candy
coated sweetened peanut butter gems yep
to a kid Zayat this seems like a cute
and organic moment
[Applause]
to a savvy or cynical adult however et's
love of Reese's Pieces is a glaring less
than magical example of Hershey approved
product placement it's a wonder et
didn't tell Elliot he needed to phone
home with AT&T the candy company's
million dollar promotional gambit worked
in the immediate wake of the film's
success sales of Reese's Pieces tripled
even decades later the advertising blitz
has proven to be profitable we believe
you can fly it's one of the most
spectacular and satisfying moments in
movie history as Elliot his brother and
his brothers friends race their bikes to
get a weekend ET back to his spaceship
they come across a road block of
government agents that want to take e.t
away and do who knows what to him it
looks like our heroes are sunk
until et uses his special powers to
launch the whole bicycle contingent up
into the sky and then fly away the
silhouette of ET and Elliot on a bike is
such an iconic image that director
Steven Spielberg used it as the logo for
his film production company Amblin
entertainment it drew you in three
visiting beloved childhood movies has
more appeal than just the nostalgia
factor we want to see if the movies we
loved as kids hold up are they
legitimately good or did we just like
them because we were dumb kids watching
as an adult you're aware of the people
behind the roles for example only an
adult will realize upon adult aged
viewing that adorable little Gertie is
actually America's Sweetheart drew
Barrymore star of Charlie's Angels in
the wedding singer what's a scent as
supreme Asst some of the insults in ET
levied by kids make no sense at all but
only an adult's ears realize that some
of these words have never been seriously
used outside of ET notably when
Michael's friend Greg calls Elliot a
Cintas supremist
just finished supremist zero
Suprema sent us a brief while the movies
subtitles spell out this strange tween
put down the words don't actually mean
anything perhaps it's a bit of fake
Latin and enduring insult slang
phenomenon best embodied by the old
chestnut
Dorcas Mallorca s' et is kind of
terrifying kids have fewer preconceived
notions than adults about the world
around them which makes them often much
more accepting and open-hearted to those
that are different at least that's one
theme of ET the kids love the little guy
straightaway and most of the adults want
to capture him run tests on him or kill
him
here's the deal though
adults have every reason to be
suspicious and terrified of et he's a
shriveled waddling mass with huge glassy
eyes not to mention he's got a long bony
light finger and a glowing a possibly
radioactive heart if the average adult
came across something in the woods that
looked like an et they wouldn't give it
hugs and Reese's Pieces they'd run away
screaming
[Music]